not a capitol hill where it's calm
tonight despite worries over a possible
repeat of the january 6th
uprising but we do have a blueprint for
how the government plans to prevent or
if necessary respond to
another such event one of the headlines
democrats apparently want walls and
wires on capitol hill but not
at the southern border national security
correspondent jennifer griffin has the
details live for us from the pentagon
tonight hi jennifer
good evening john speaker pelosi tasked
retired lieutenant general
russell honore to lead a task force to
make recommendations about how to secure
the u.s capitol
today my colleague lucas tomlinson and i
obtained a 33-page draft copy
of the report while also learning the
capitol police have asked the national
guard to stay
an additional two months fox news
exclusively obtained a copy of the u.s
capitol security recommendations made by
retired lieutenant general russell
honore and his task force among the
recommendations establish
a full-time quick reaction force manned
24 7
365 days a year at the u.s capitol
at a cost of between 40 and 130 million
dollars per year
the options include using existing
federal law enforcement entities
or mobilizing the national guard for
three to six month rotations
or create a permanent active duty d.c
national guard
military police battalion issue about
the national guard is one
that will be made by the the capitol
police and the police board and the rest
but i'm not in a position to respond to
that but we should have them here
as long as they are needed but pelosi
and the senate majority leader oversee
the capitol police board that the
capitol police answer to
more recommendations earpieces for the
cops and mounted police
and overhaul the canine unit which has
too many quote aging dogs
among the infrastructure upgrades repair
and replace
doors and windows and add retractable
fencing
quote as the fencing comes down we
recommend it be replaced with a mobile
fencing option
last month general honore who has a long
passed as a vocal gop
critic claimed u.s capitol police and
the house and senate sergeants at arms
were complicit in the capitol riot i've
just never seen so much incompetence
so they're either that stupid or
ignorant or they complicit i think they
were complicit
questions have been raised by lawmakers
who say the task force appointed by
pelosi was not
bipartisan the task force also
recommended home security systems for
all members of congress because it says
threats to members have increased
fourfold in the past year
tenant general honore is speaker
pelosi's appointee
there was no consultation with
republicans
this was not a bipartisan effort
today however after intelligence
warnings placed 5200 national guard on
high alert
at the capitol the threat from qnon to
the capital
never materialized the task force also
recommended hiring 884
more police officers who we learned from
the report
put in for an eye-popping 720 thousand
hours of overtime last year it also
recommends an increase in background
checks for capitol hill
identification cards and adding card
readers to quote
decrease insider threat risks john
jennifer griffin with that exclusive
reporting tonight jennifer
thank you